so thank you all for coming I'm super
excited about the group that we've been
able to pull together today it's the
first twenty plus years of long now has
really been us kind of acting as a
startup and executing on some of the
first projects like the 10,000 year
clock which is nearing completion now in
West Texas and certain library projects
like the Rosetta project Laura's here
today we'll be talking a bit about
language and culture as well and and
that first 20 to 25 years we're now
looking at as long now is kind of q1 and
if that's our q1 project
what is our q2 project and and I when we
started this we realized very much that
engineering o'clock is a difficult
problem a 10,000 year clock but
engineering a 10,000 year institution is
really the hardest problem that we could
ever work on and so I think that this is
really going to be long now as next big
project is how to build long term
institutions and as I started diving
into it I realize there's there's really
no there's there's no discipline there's
no broad study of this anywhere nobody
is nobody is a long term institution
expert and so this seems like the thing
for long now to do not only for
ourselves as the first customer but also
for the world there's there there has to
be some great practices and knowledge
that we can pull together and be the
clearinghouse for this kind of thing so
this is the very first gathering in this
space and nobody here is really from a
very long-term institution necessarily I
think that's going to be our next one of
these gatherings is going to be bringing
those people together but this one is
the one where we get to think very very
broadly and we're looking at natural
systems language and culture some of
that historical precedence of of
the past and how these things work and
I've pulled together my research so far
on long term institutions and what I
want today to be as much as possible is
a discussion among all of us so we have
a bunch of short presentations that's
going to be punctuated by QA as well as
as discussion we've tried to do our best
to arrange these chairs so you can kind
of see each other as we as we work today
and with that I'm gonna start today off
with Peter Schwartz who wrote founding
board member here at Long now and is
actually the person who suggested the
time frame that long now works under of
10,000 years and and he wrote a book
called the art of the long view which
many of you may know and it is kind of
the de-facto book on how companies and
institutions can actually think over
long periods of time so I thought it
would be the perfect way for us to start
so with that Peter thank you Zander
first of all let me say thank you to you
more generally for pulling this together
this is a great subject not you won't be
surprised to know that we began thinking
about this when long now first started
as we you know the the earliest
discussions of which several of the
Stewart and others are in the room when
when we did that and we had we actually
struggled with this question you know
are there already and and you know the
only ones we could really come up with
were like the Catholic Church right so
well you know this is it can't be our
models right I mean you know Stewart is
not the Pope not gonna happen that way
and we are not the acolytes of the Pope
so that isn't gonna happen I'll take
this thank you and so we struggled
actually with trying to find were there
organizations and institutions that we
could learn from and the truth is there
weren't many oxford university and that
you know the story of the beams and all
of that that was you know we looked at a
few of those we looked at a couple of
old companies before gbn started we had
something called the learning
conferences that Danica ran and Stewart
and several others were involved in and
we thought about it then but we still
didn't come up with any good answers to
be honest you know we kept coming back
to this in a variety of ways and each
time we struggled with this question so
I'm really delighted
we're finally taking on the question at
least in the beginning in a serious way
because we've never really confronted
this question except kind of
peripherally in our conversations and
frankly have not made much progress that
I think of so I think this is a good
starting point and as a starting point
basically what I wanted this is about a
tool so I'm gonna talk a little bit just
simply for a few minutes about the tool
of scenario planning as a tool for
thinking about the long term because
that's what I know how to do and so it's
just a little bit of an introduction so
think about this as a tool for thinking
about what we're gonna think about okay
that's the way to think about what I'm
going to talk about right and it really
begins with I look back at this several
people in this room can give this talk
just as well a Katherine Fulton and
Lawrence Wilkinson back there and Stuart
overall use this slide many times but
this it makes a fundamental point and
this is of course an antique map you
probably have several versions of this
one ABI I have this one happens to be I
own this one it's in my in my office at
Salesforce but it making one very
important point and that is that we make
our decisions and what we think about
the future based on our own mental maps
about how the world works
and why things happen as they do and we
are limited by those and part of the
function of scenario planning a part of
our challenge is how do you break out of
that how are we need to break out of the
constraints so the story of this map is
really quite interesting this is of
course a map of North America and it was
made by a Dutch map maker by the name of
Herman mole working in London in 1701 I
I bought it actually on a Portobello
Road for about 60 pounds back in 1981 so
not particularly valuable I have a whole
book of maps like this because of course
you see something unusual about this map
right you wouldn't want to use this map
would you and in fact I have a whole
book of maps of California's an island
and what's interesting is how the map
came to be how it was used and out was
changed because the Spanish obviously
came up from the south had they found
what we now call Mex
go and the tip of the Baja Peninsula
sailed up into the Sea of Cortez said
alright this thing seems to go pretty
far north then they came up further
north and eventually to what we call the
straits of Juan de Fuca the North
straits they sailed in there down into
there and said oh this must be connected
and they created the island of
California now this would only be a
historical curiosity were not for the
problem of the missionaries who actually
used the map to go inland and of course
they would have to take their boats with
them to cross the sea of California and
of course when they went over the Sierra
Nevada mountains down the other side
they found this beach that went on and
on and on and on until finally they
realized there's no sea of California
and they write back to the mapmakers in
Spain and say your bloody map is wrong
and the map makers write back and say no
no no you're in the wrong place the map
is right anybody who works in a large
organization understands that logic very
well right
does that daddy the map is always right
well this one was the the king of the
the first maps for 1605 that were drawn
this way this one is 1701 the king of
Spain finally figured out that this was
wrong and ordered the maps in 1685 to
change in Spain
the last one is 1765 that were drawn
this way so what's the message you get
your facts wrong you get your map wrong
you get your map wrong you do the wrong
thing but worst of all once you believe
a map it's very hard to change and I
think that's a lot of our challenge is
how do we actually challenge those
mental maps that we see about how people
behave how organizations work how
institutions evolve what the nature of a
society is and so on we are very much
prisoners of our existing metal maps and
what good scenario planning does is help
you break those maps that's really what
it's all about
I'm now going to show you the most
costly slide in business history this is
a two hundred billion dollar slide
that's right two hundred billion dollars
and this is a slide of the sales of
personal computers now while it looks
like this is that this is an actual
photograph of an overhead transparency
from 1984 those of you who are too young
that is how we used to do slides right
overheads right you put them on a little
box with a light underneath them so this
is an actual copy it was given to me by
IBM so there's not
I didn't steal this and what's
fascinating is this was the slide that
was used by IBM to make the decision
about the future of personal computers
should we go into this business or not
what should we do and they did a
forecast right of what the demand was
you can see here you can't read in the
back there but the total through all
channels over five years two hundred and
forty-one thousand six hundred and
eighty-three peaking in nineteen
eighty-three and heading south because
no one would buy a second one right this
product was so funky that you know the
theory was this this was gonna kill
Apple that was the goal get people back
to real computers because real men use
big machines hard big iron right these
were all there was nine men in the room
and they got it obviously totally wrong
anybody know what the right answer was
about twenty five million so they were a
little bit off and they said well okay
two hundred forty one thousand a couple
thousand dollars a unit well it's not
worth developing a chip Intel give us
the chip and this is kid from Seattle
gates or something that's got a
operating system called kudos he'll give
it to us for free we'll put it on the
machine and put it in a box we'll call
it an IBM computer it was that moment
they almost lost the future of the
company because they could not imagine
that the world could be so different
that people would like a box with 16 K
of memory in it that just seemed
inconceivable to these nine men who were
the smartest people in their industry
who knew everything about what they were
doing and got it completely wrong and
literally almost killed IBM as a result
of course they no longer bake pcs
because it could no longer compete etc
so this is why Bill Gates is the richest
man in the world is this slide if IBM
and said you know maybe there really is
a future here and we'll develop our own
operating system and our own chips it
might have been a very different story
so part of our challenge today in our
thinking in conversation is precisely
that how do we challenge each other's
mettle maps fortunately this room is not
a bunch of old white guys but diversity
is the single most important
characteristics for thinking about the
future
the single every time I have been wrong
with no exceptions it's because we had
inadequate diversity in the room there
are a number of embarrassing moments in
the history of GB and
Mexico meeting being maybe the lowest
pointed GB in history when in two weeks
before the collapse of the Mexican peso
we said there are three scenarios for
Mexico good better and best in two weeks
later it all went in the tank and why
because we were all just talking to
ourselves we got it completely wrong so
that's really one of the most important
messages about long-term thinking is
really that diversity of point of view
and if you're trapped in one mindset
you're gonna miss an enormous amount
okay so I often like this quote and that
is that often do the spirits of great
events tried on before the events and in
today already walks tomorrow and it's
that the signals are out there right so
you know the future is being born we all
remember the bill Gibson quote of the
future is already here it's just not
evenly spread right so out there
somewhere there's the the signals and
that's part of the function of a group
like this and why diversity actually
matters a lot is being able to pick up
on that variety of signals from a
variety of different disciplines context
cultures etc and that's an important
part of what scenario thinking is about
an important way to think about this the
way most organizations have thought
about the future forever was this kind
of project out from the present and then
you know if they were concerned about
uncertainty they shaded it up and down a
little bit 10% up 10% down and said you
know that was called sensitivity
analysis didn't require much imagination
required math but scenario planning
involves imagining different
possibilities and then how we can get
from here to there and so it is required
as a combination of two things
imagination and analytic realism that is
actually you know honey where's honey
honey orogeny me here's a great science
fiction writer requires a lot of
imagination and some rigor he can break
some of the rules of today when he
writes about the world of three hundred
years from now and but nevertheless we
still have to have rigorous thing if
it's pure fantasy that's all it is is
fantasy right if it's pure imagination
even good stuff is sci-fi for it to
really be realistic it has to be a
combination of both if it's just
forecast
just analysis going forward it's
pedestrian you missed the big surprises
you don't see that new mental map if
it's just imagination without analysis
and rigor behind it it is just that it's
good fiction so it's important that both
of these come to bear in the task of
thinking about scenarios okay
the real test here and and this is
probably where I want to stop is that
it's not really about prediction it's
about making better decisions that is if
you really do your homework well in
multiple scenarios you're probably going
to see this future that's that the hard
part actually the hard part is what do
you do and if your scenarios are
brilliant and nobody pays any attention
you have failed
having been a consultant for many years
it was not a way to get more business to
say to a CEO well we gave you the future
and you blew it you didn't make the
right decision that was our failure as a
consultant our job was to actually
affect the mindset of decision makers
and I think that is what we're doing
here is in the end what we really want
to do is not simply understand long term
institutions but influence them how do
we actually make better decisions about
our societies our governments our
corporations our educational
institutions our communities how do we
actually think long term and make better
choices so that's the real goal here is
actually beginning to think long term
about what is likely to happen and it is
a conversation so we call it I think it
is the next slide yes right it is
basically about it and this is well and
it's about a strategic conversation and
that's really what we want to empower
here is really thinking about different
scenarios going out subsequently you're
thinking about a discipline creating new
knowledge doing research doing serious
homework beginning to think about how
you create what we call emergent
strategies basically strategies that
emerge out of that conversation as
opposed to top-down control this is
gonna happen testing those against what
we're already doing and improving the
quality of decision making so what this
is really about is an orchestrated
strategic conversation is what we're
gonna have today with inputs from a
variety of different sources think
possible scenarios thinking about how we
might influence the shape of
institutions going forward what the
rules for those might be and this
continues on this doesn't stop this
conversation is a perpetual long Dao
conversation thank you thank you
[Applause]
and Peter well look I mean organizations
have been think about things like this
for a long time but the formal
discipline actually began with the
military shortly after World War two
where they really was about planning for
the Cold War and RAND Corporation which
stood for R and D was set up by the Air
Force to do long-term planning for
deterrence and a guy named Herman Kahn
and Andy Marshall came up with
essentially the idea of scenarios of
different models of the future of
conflict in fact Stewart many years ago
in the whole earth days interviewed
Herman on stage I remember I was in the
audience for that one party is that
recorded somewhere Stewart I think so I
seem to remember some footage from it
years later yeah but anyway so Herman
was the real first formal futurist in
that sense and then it really morphed in
moved to the business community in the
1970s and then shell took it on and I
was the head of scenario planning for
shell but it has now become the kind of
universal discipline that virtually
every organization does it more or less
seriously thank you very much I found
one of the most important things with
scenarios as well from the workshops
that that we did with G beyond a long
time ago that not only does it it
informs the conversation but that the
most important thing that I saw it doing
was that it it prepared you for that
world so that you you could actually
believe that that world might happen and
so even if it was a really bad scenario
or a really good scenario those
scenarios rarely play it out exactly the
way anyone thought but
the indicators would allow the
leadership of a company to go oh hold on
I just saw this little thing that came
up in our story or something very close
to it and now I realize we're moving
towards that scenario and I think
preparing those minds was one of the
best things that scenario planning did
you